I am so excited for my talk at the table
because I'm talking to the one and only
you as in Jackman you know him as the
iconic character Wolverine in the X-Men
franchise and his Unforgettable leading
roles in stuff like the greatest showman
and Les Miserables he was just nominated
for a Golden Globe for his performance
in his new film it's called the sun this
is a really different role for Hugh
Jackman he plays a father who is trying
his best to take care of his teenage son
who has been struggling with mental
health issues here's a look
starting tomorrow
whether you like it or not you're going
back to school is that clear no sorry
saying no I will not go back to school
what are you doing Nicholas what do you
want
when I was your age my mother was sick I
wasn't seeing my father anymore I had
money problems but I fought on I fought
on and believe me most days it was no
joke and what has happened to you what
is there in your life that is so
dramatic you're not able to go to school
like everybody else answer me that's I
can't deal with it don't understand what
that means you can't deal with what
living I I can't deal with living and
it's your fault
oh no parent ever wants to hear that
it's your fault Hugh Jackman joins us
now good morning to you Hugh Jackman
you're so good to see you I'm sitting
here holding the thing it says best
performance by an actor in a motion
picture drama Hugh Jackman the son what
did you thank you when you got this news
why not because I handed that to you
um I was greatly on it it's a huge
thrill and it's a role I'm really proud
of in a film that I worked with
Incredible people and a story that I
really think needs to be told so this is
all wonderful icing all I can say is
well deserved I think you've upped the
bar but this role when I think about
this role for you I think we're seeing
you in a way that we haven't seen you
before but when you first read the
script you actually reached out to the
director
yeah one of the you normally don't do
that no one of the great motivators an
actor can ever get is when their agent
rings and said listen there's this
amazing role but they're talking to a
couple of other actors I'm like really
um but I knew Florian Zeller's work so
uh for audiences who don't know Florian
he just recently did the film The Father
which he won the Oscar for and Anthony
Hopkins won the Oscar four or two years
ago and
um he's written many plays I almost did
one of his plays so I knew his work I
did not know the sun I knew of it I read
it that day and I was like in my gut
yeah Gail I felt I had to play this part
yeah I really wanted this story to be
tall and I wanted to be part of it so I
thought I remember Asian said I'm just
going to email him but I'd heard he was
talking to someone else so I I think I
said something like I hear you may be
dancing with someone else I'm not the
kind of guy to cut in on a dance so but
if you haven't made a decision but if
you're not I would I just said I'd laid
my cards in the time I said I'd love to
play the part well go Mr Zeller me the
next day and offer me the part yeah you
all were talking over Zoom he knew that
you were the one but you this is what
struck me number one I have to say this
movie is very hard to watch it takes you
on such a journey between a parent and a
child between a father and a son between
divorce there's all sorts of layers in
this movie but you have said that this
has changed you as a parent how
I think I've learned it's okay to not
know it's okay to lead with
vulnerability I mean I have a 22 and a
17 year old so they're kind of adult
they're adults so in this age range of
this movie yes in the story it's a 17
year old and I think this area of Mental
Health
there's a line in the movie that says
love is not enough it's not always
enough it's the most important thing of
course but sometimes when you're dealing
with Mental Health crisis we we need to
rely on other people and I think as a
parent I will now say things to my kids
like
I am I don't know I'm actually not sure
um give me a second I'm sorry I'm
feeling a bit nervous or scared I I know
I may I'm sorry if I look disappointed
I'm not disappointed I'm just worried
have you not done that before no I think
in the past I was more like they want to
see stability they want to see strength
and Surety and confidence as a father
you know that that will help them but I
think sometimes they I see it in their
face they go oh that's all right Dad
yeah no let's I say can we just talk
about this together because I'm not sure
what to do here yeah um I'm worried but
I don't know how to handle it there is a
very powerful scene in the movie where
the sun you know the doctors are giving
you one advice and the son is saying no
no no and I watched that scene and it
ripped me apart because who do you
believe in that moment the son is saying
no don't make me do this the doctor is
saying You must do this it's a big back
and forth and ultimately the parents
make the decision and they were
comfortable with that decision that
scene really got to me you because I put
what do you do in a situation like that
where your child is pleading with you
begging with you and telling you I'm
going to be fine I just need your
support take me out of here this is
making it worse and the doctor's saying
no trust me I wouldn't do this with mice
it's it's an impossible situation there
is no no and that's the horrible hard
fact about being a parent you make
mistakes you don't know what to do and
you're making them under stress and
under pressure and without necessarily
the knowledge and I think what this
movie is doing is starting conversations
saying it's okay to not know it's okay
to lean on other people it's okay to
take a second it's okay to say I'm not
sure give me a moment and to realize it
takes a village to raise a child it
really does it does and in the middle of
this movie you lose your own father I
met your dad back in the day God he was
something else he was so lovely so kind
so proud of you so really proud of you
and didn't mind saying that and shortly
after his death you have to shoot a very
emotional scene did that play into what
I was when I was watching it I thought
boy he was really going in and I didn't
know at the time the timing of your
father's death in relation to that scene
did that make a difference for you in
that moment
yeah it was I I would say whilst doing
this movie the the subject matter as
well as my father passing
um covert I felt I was a bit of a hot
mess scale I yeah I was in sleeping
great I I gave myself over to the
process and I it was very healing
ultimately but that day
when I shot that very emotional scene I
remember thinking I need to lean on
everybody here
often in the past I've had a very
emotional scene I'll just get into my
own world and I was like oh no I need
here like the crew the camera the sound
people everyone I need to roll and I
felt my father's presence that was a
beautiful surprise for me I could feel
him sort of in the corner and his love
and just and
that got me through it's a beautiful
scene may I just say the crew will
always get you through it's always been
my experience a crew will always get you
through it will true you I know I
actually wrote in my journal that
morning and we were talking about
sharing before journaling now yes I was
a little you know my therapist was like
dude you need to start journaling and I
was like what did you think I was like
oh homework I've heard journaling all
right it's gratitude Journal let's do
the journal
I will not wake up without doing my
journal now every day it starts with I
feel there's I don't know
maybe it's more typical of men than
women but I'm not I haven't even as an
actor no it's necessarily women men to
write I feel because exactly I don't
think we're that articulate yeah and I
wasn't that articulate about what I was
feeling I would write things like
confused and says never I confused I
said but I feel confused he goes no you
don't you just feel two things at once
write both things down I feel this I
feel angry and I feel relieved that's
good and and parts of me feel this
possibly so now it really really helps
me and anyway I wrote that morning in my
journal the names of every one of the
crew and I said I'm going to need Bob
I'm going to need yes I need Tony I need
Patty I need Klaus I need lady Lee I so
get it I so get it and Wolverine and
Deadpool yes what is happening there
because everyone thought Wolverine has
done but it seems like Wolverine might
be coming back in Denver Wolverine is
coming back
um how are you feeling about we don't
like to say it in Deadpool we like to
say Deadpool's coming back into the
Wolverine movie generally to be clear
just to be clear
um I really thought I was done and and
by the way Ryan honestly
emailed me rang me texted me hounded me
four years and I was honestly like dude
I'm out I'm out August 14th I remember I
was just driving and it came to me like
that I'm not done I want to do it and I
rang him immediately and he said he said
yep let's do it so we're doing it so
very special and I was there opening
night for music man I was in row H
screaming did you remember me I was
wearing yellow I remembered yeah the
only thing I remember
he's good so you're wrapping up January
January 15th we have five weeks five
weeks later you ready yeah that's been
an amazing run and I'm ready to move on
to new things and but I'm gonna miss
that everybody in that theater there's
150 people in that theater every single
day I love them and I'm going to miss
them like crazy but uh yeah yeah but
Hugh Jackman they love you we all love
you and we are cheering you on Golden
Globes congratulations thank you my best
to your lovely wife I will I'll pass
that on as soon as I get here
I feel the same Hugh Jackman in the the
movie called The Sun opens Nationwide on
Winter's hope Nationwide you it's open
oh Nationwide
um which one oh
this is so early I'm doing shows at
night it's early no we're glad you're
January 20th
January